[Music]
if I can have your attention we would I
would like to introduce our luncheon
speaker I'm Arthur Kerman bill wall
Meyers someone who in the proverbial
phrase doesn't need any introduction
because almost all of us have had
something to do with him over the last
thirty years or longer he we were really
pleased to hear that he had had positive
enough feelings about L&S to come to
this celebration and to give us a little
talk about his interaction with us he
tells me that before he went to the BOE
thirty years ago he was the director of
the accelerator division at Mura which
is something goes way to the distant
past
if I remember right it was an
organization that was supposed to design
some accelerators but he's been at the
DOA since since 1962 and a head of
high-energy physics basically all that
time and of course not since 1962
because four years ago or five years ago
he became president of Sura Southeastern
University's Research Association and
I've had some interactions with him
recently because of sea bass but during
the time he was at D OE we always look
to him to make the right decisions about
the physics and as I said it very happy
that he agreed to come and address us
and without further ado bill Walmart
thank you
I didn't know I was supposed to say good
things about LNS that wasn't what lead
Grogg he didn't give me that condition
yeah Lee called me some time ago and
though I really can't speak and you'll
find that out later
I'm always week and say yes when
somebody calls me early enough these
always been in front of me for many
years he and I were Purdue together and
even though he's younger than I he was
working on his ph.d while I was still
working on my master's also one of our
colleagues in the physics department
taking pity on the poor graduate
students may her male graduate fellow
graduate students in the physics
department got us together for a coke
date with some of her sorority sisters
and though I thought I was pretty fast
and calling one of the young ladies Lee
had already had a date with her by the
time I called fortunately she did
reluctantly schedule me on to and she is
my wife of the day but anyways a sailor
I heard Vicki this morning talked about
the fact that as you get older the years
get shorter and by gosh they get shorter
other things that happen of course is
it's really true what they say say it
gets so you can't remember names and
alright Kerman and I were going through
something about the first name and then
the last name of Yin's with a k' etc and
that kind of thing but one of the one of
the difficulties I've had and problems
I've had is that I get older it gets
later and later before I start trying to
prepare what I'm going to say as a
condition as a result of that I've well
past the point towards I won't be
prepared for this talk until
time next week as you'll find but a few
words anyway Lee and and and the program
committee gave me a title of LNS through
the eyes of the funders and I said well
that sounds ok I'm taking that to mean
the view from a former do a program
office of the do II and therefore I we
apologize to my friends particularly
which I've been more interacting with in
recent years than before and nuclear
physics and that most of what I'll talk
to will relate to experiences in high
energy physics though certainly LNS is
even more on nuclear physics lab at the
present time certainly in terms of
funding then than it is high energy
physics Sam thing must be quiet or
something but anyway the the the for
example the current funding in 92 I'm
told for nuclear physics at LNS is some
16 million while in haunted your physics
is somewhat less than 10 still by the
way in each program the largest
university contractor of all both in
nuclear physics and in high energy
physics anyway have a few words here of
the program office is working at the
interface between science and government
I have in that position in the past been
privileged to walk among the Giants on
both sides of that interface I would say
I've done my best and haven't been
squashed too badly by their feet but
many of those giants indeed have chawed
the pass of LNS the PTO people of great
stature people of dedication and
commitment highest quality always
willing to give themselves fully in the
interest of the program and science I
can't recall in all the many years that
indeed I did have the program office
behind your physics at BOE that I asked
somebody to serve on a committee to do
something for the program that they said
anything but yes it's hard to believe
but it's indeed true that's the kind of
people that are in the field and I must
say that my colleagues at that time in
the funding agency were very much the
same though the government has
government worker gets bad marks from
certainly from presidential candidates
the ones that I worked with I found of
outstanding commitment and indeed high
capability it I think part of that of
course was associated with the program
that both not only the scientists but
also the government employees agreed
agreed that it was indeed a most
worthwhile and meaningful effort in
which to be involved I know I can't come
to death how about that I'd like to say
just a few marks because remarks about
the federal support for science the
federal government became a major player
in the support of science and basic
research after World War two and
coincidentally the beginning of Ln s
I of course puzzled maybe why some of
the things I think are obvious it's a
recognition of the importance and the
great contributions that the academic
community made to the war effort
things such as some very close to here
the radio radar proximity fuze nuclear
power other things and indeed as I think
we learned earlier Bruno Rossi Viki
Weisskopf Jerrold Zacharias and what no
not Martin Deutsch Martin was here well
before he may return but
well before the 46 I think I learned to
do it well I won't tell Martin Martin's
been here quite a while from the Los
Alamos effort to work here at that time
in 46 the other thing is I think the
federal establishment recognized that
the u.s. was most fortunate in World War
2 to have been able to draw on the
European science and scientists for our
effort here the other thing is is that
the federal government is the most
appropriate place and that's been
recognized certainly very strongly in
recent administration's most appropriate
place to support basic research the
payoff of basic research I think we're
all well assured it is well assured we
all know is well assured but where and
when is too uncertain for a private
industry and then of course there was a
there was a major shock in 1957 with the
launching of Sputnik to the US who
thought that clearly we would do that
first and I even when I joined the AEC
and June of 62 I could still see the
funding effective that going through the
system the agencies for support of this
during these years the Department of
Defense in particular or on our which
was a most outstanding and superb
organization for the support of research
those defense agencies primarily pulled
out of the support of basic research in
about the mid 60s with a Mansfield Act
then the other support of course has
been from the Atomic Energy Committee
with with from the Atomic Energy
Commission most appropriate and high
energy and nuclear physics since most of
the people
wanted to work in that area many of the
people who would have work in that area
came to the Manhattan Project and then I
think it was about 1951 they start with
about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars as I recall the start of the
National Science Foundation as the first
and I guess still the only dedicated
science support entirely support agency
I've got lots of time here man ok well I
will try to go through this without your
pleasant the pleasant part has you've
had with your meal of course so I'll
show you a few graphs see just a second
and say a few words about them as a
background for a few comments I want to
make I hope the backgrounds not too long
I'll try to shorten it as I said as I
told art I hadn't really I didn't know
how long I'd talk because I had prepared
to talk as a background for a few
remarks I want to make about thank you
is that big switch anything there that's
all of you know are you physics is an
exploratory science which is at the
forefront of science and technology and
for understanding of the most
fundamental nature of matter and energy
it pushes the front care of each the
science and the technology and since the
beginnings of LNS you heard some and
you'll hear more you have been have
fantastic advantage excuse me advances
in knowledge and understanding which
have been made in high-energy and
nuclear physics and cosmology during
this during this time and not all before
which can possibly be of course
discussed
this at this meeting some
characteristics of the research which
I've noted is that it's and this holds
very much for nuclear is high energy not
quite as much because it's not quite as
cohesive high energy is very cohesive
and strongly focused in this direction
by the fact is trying to find out the
most fundamental that's about matter and
energy and the myth is a study which
require very large machines are very few
machines and and therefore you you all
have to work together to get you had to
decide which one you're going to get you
had to work hard to get it because it's
also very expensive hard to get the sort
of a bootstrap science and my way of
thinking in that experiment advances
Theory requires advances in technology
which permits advancement experiment etc
very strong international effect the
first point I've noted I saw it
expressed well before I and I can't
remember the words you have a human
friendly cooperation and collaboration
and very fierce competition and fighting
and this works it's not only in the
international arena and we've been
seeing some of it in recent years but it
also works individual scientists the
individual scientists group the group
school to school lab to lab but somehow
it works well to help advance the field
and the long lead-time nature this this
graph this chart undoubted is little old
because I think it's much more than
three to five years from a research
proposal to publication and much more
than eight to ten years from
construction proposal to experimental
use as I recall the SSC for example was
first decided as something that hired
new physics should go up on during the
July the 12th 1983 which is already nine
years ago
well I'll never get to if it'll go fast
in this really so
the issues and problems long lead times
therefore long-range planning isn't very
crucially important funding stability is
very difficult to get particularly in
these days though we have more funding
stability in science than many parts of
the national effort which is funded by
the national program worldwide
competitive position well the certainly
the US has come from a commanding
leadership position to a sharing
leadership position that's not all bad
it's quite good
new technology development as we said
before is important for permitting the
advances and accelerators and detector
capability that are needed for the field
to advance the structure of the national
program do e acts as the executive agent
or the lead agency therefore bear
special responsibility for long-range
planning for a balanced national program
and for trying to maintain the u.s. in a
in a world at least a sharing world
leadership rule do he has has since I've
been there in 62 and his predecessor
agencies and AEC provided over 90% of
the federal support in the early days
when I was there in early 60s much of
that other five to ten seven to ten
percent came out of the Defense agencies
shifting in about the mid 60s
that shifted in the mid 60s towards the
NSF and of course it for a long time
that's been entirely the National
Science Foundation the crucial thing
that's been true
of the program since the since it was
initiated was the first Standing
Committee Advisory Committee he PAP 67
okay the role of the university's you
well know
role of leadership role of doing most of
the experiments theory and and and
training the new people the one of the
responsibilities of the do II as the
lead agency as I said was a balancing of
the the program and the factors in and
the balancing of course there's a good
balance between utilization between
construction for the next phase and for
advanced technology Rd and other
preventive is to go farther than that to
get the machines that are needed beyond
that the structure of the do ii program
is of course three large labs a large
number of experimental users many
theorists and the much advancement a
much involvement in the advanced
technology development primarily that
the national laboratories the other
agency supporting this of course is a
National Science Foundation their
support is essentially all to
universities and they support users they
support theory and they support the
what's called the university laboratory
at Cornell but of course this is also a
National Laboratory Caeser though the
Department of Energy supports
dollar-wise well over ninety percent of
the program the National Science
Foundation supports approximately
one-third of the University the support
needed for the program
they major objectives of the department
hopefully obvious and hopefully the same
as the programs a high quality
productive program with diversity and
flexibility to operate the facilities
reliably to construct the new ones
that's needed to develop the technology
needed to extend the capabilities to
help maintain the US and a and a
competitive world position a summary the
program philosophy is shown here where
the ideas and proposals are generated
from the ground up by the scientists in
the field the agency with input from the
field and with input from advisory
mechanisms establishes the policy plans
tries to get the money in budgets the
laboratory management or the university
principal investigator has the
responsibility for the day-to-day
management and the latter I put on some
time we'll go for de the an important
function of the program office at its
interface position I'm not going to go
through this but just to show the
complexity of it is to try and deed to
get the funding for the program and this
is this is for all programs and it's
it's so lengthy is so complex one
wonders that that the money ever comes
out at the end or it even matches the
needs but you start from the individual
physicists through their their lab or
university organization and each time of
course it gets consolidated and
and integrated with other and then you
go then that those individual programs
go to the high-energy physics office and
it's worked on their using he pap and
others and all kinds of advice goes on
up through the do-e system recognized by
the representative that dotted box up to
the Office of Management and Budget it
bounces back and forth by the way at
each of those parts you fight and as
they cut and there you try to get
restore in that kind of thing goes up to
office and management budget which gets
some advice and some participant lis a
consultant and working with me at Sarah
Hugh Lewis
he worked very closely with the
president's science advisor office and
it was quite effective and I think that
still carries on up through the
president over to the Congress where
there's of course a House and Senate and
there are three types of committees
there one in each each each each arm
there's a budget committee which decides
how much in general should go split you
take the total for the nation you split
that amongst all the various categories
and then there's the authorization
committee which hasn't been very
effective and very active recently for
Department of Energy and then you have
the Appropriations committees that
really have to decide how much money you
get that comes down then that all comes
back down the same way okay
the let's see I'd like to show a few
budget graphs here because they
certainly relate they really relate to
LNS in a number of ways there's a pretty
one the old only goes doctor fiscal 90
which shows construction excuse me
operating and blue equipment in red and
green earth construction and the
Weiskopf years as chairman of the high-g
physics advisory
were 67 to 74 there they're followed by
the dwell years from 74 to 82 followed
by the San Weiss years up to 87 em
Francis lo came on from 87 to 90 and now
Stanwood jiske Vicki had no Vicki
started out in a rather affluent or
seemingly relatively affluent area he
had a most difficult job he not only had
to set the rules and set the precedence
for he PAP but he also had to deal with
the fact that first the budget was
growing he put the he PAP put together a
very extensive study group all kinds of
subcommittees it took 18 months to come
out with a very thorough comprehensive
report on where hydrophytic should be
going and what it should be doing I
still have several copies they're very
they're very good unfortunately you take
if you take a look at 16 Isis fiscal 69
and so actually if you take a look at
calendar 69 you're really dealing more
like with fiscal 71 70 71 the budget
things that happen we're in they were in
the I guess the Vietnam War I can still
remember one specific thing that
happened to my program as I recall it
was about November the Appropriations
had already been happened had already
happened and Lyndon Johnson told Wilbur
Mills that he wanted next to tax a
little extra money to help carry out
both guns and butter and Wilbur said
well let's see you cut the budget first
he did cut the budget as I recall Harney
to physics itself lost ten million
dollars that's already been appropriated
and then Wilbur didn't give him
taxes either but from that time which
was there for fiscal that would have
been about fiscal 70 fiscal 69 or 70
particularly if you look at the
operating represented by the blue line
there was a slide and the support and
that by the way that wasn't just hiring
to get was fur that was for all of
science so Vicki had and he pap had to
deal with this and here's a graph like
you're gonna be lost with but I like it
because it says a lot of things and let
me point to a few the green line here is
CEA for example and this is the each
line represents the total funding
support to that laboratory during that
period I mean all separate there's no
integration here you have the Fermilab
growing here you have as I say the CEA
terminating here PPA terminating about a
year earlier you have remember this is
Vicki in here from about this period to
about about this period so you have all
these accelerators here that are coming
on and terminating and you end up here
at the end of this period was three
laboratories for well sorry Fermilab
this is a Brookhaven 80s the green here
is slack and down here as a CGS that we
managed to keep operating by three more
to three more years we're saying how
important it was to do polarized photons
studies yeah but anyway I wanted to show
that even though it's difficult to
understand this show that in this in
this in this bodes that you saw here the
time from the boat to the time when it
was really going down
that was when Vickie was chairing the he
path and and that was when
he pepper got tremendous I was I was
told that it was the most respected
government Advisory Committee in all of
Washington and a major reason why that
was true it was that by the mechanism of
he PAP and the credibility mechanism
being that people had a form they could
they could argue their case they thought
fairly we could shut down machines and
there's rather straightforward way so
there was a there's a lot of credibility
given the he PAP and that this was done
and it was able to do this in a
responsible I think that's a good part
of why they they had that okay I just
show this to show a longer history that
goes to the days funding in high-energy
physics it shows that and fiscal 93 the
budget which isn't determined yet and
which isn't going to go up it's going to
go down now this does not include the
SSC I did show some I won't go back to
it I did show some things for the SSC on
the last on the last one
the the marks that you see here here
here here and up to about here
represents the SSC funding on top of the
hydrophilics so this budget which is
this particular one which goes all the
way back to 1960 not back to OH&S time
but shows that there's about three
hundred and six hundred and twenty
million dollars total in fiscal ninety
three dollars in fiscal 93 which is a
decrease in the fact now the nuclear
physics program their records they don't
graph back at four but they go back to
77 you can see some of the problems that
Bates is going to have or is having and
some of the problems in nuclear physics
program is having if you pay attention
to the operating it goes up to here and
this is a new operating for C bath and
so you see even with the new operating
for Seba that the operating level with
which pays for operations and includes
research and in terms of constant value
dollars is certainly going down in 93
at the at the highest funding that that
nuclear physics will have and that's
that's a large part of course because of
the major construction has taking part
in that program both at sea bath and
Rick and indeed and a much smaller scale
but a very significant scale also just
completing with the Bates upgrade
upgrade with what is the SH or the South
Hall ring okay I'll just show this to
you for curiosity this is a total
manpower supported by high energy and
nuclear physics the orange represents
the manpower in the universities with
PhDs and graduate students and the top
is assembly thing for for laboratory see
you did say I had to okay thank you
thank you well okay there's a critical
need for new facility since we have an
exploratory science and since what we're
doing in this science is the only way we
advanced is being able to operate in a
new physical domain and how do you get
into a new physical domain you get into
of course a new accelerator capability
or a new positive great capability or
neutrino detectors what have you for
that so
at the present time the world's
accelerators in terms of luminosity and
center of mass the u.s. plans at least
still keep us I've got a red check by
all the u.s. machines and the u.s. plans
with the SSC and the territory upgrades
keep us to keep us indeed competitive on
a machine capability in world
accelerator laboratories of course are
the ones here in the US you have the
ones you know of Western Europe Germany
Soviet Russia Japan PRC then you have an
increasing importance being given to non
accelerator laboratories which we have
two in the US the one in an old iron
mine up in Minnesota and the one in a
salt mine in Ohio Gran Sasso which
several people here have experiments box
on and you Soviet Union and comió condi
well as you all know international
collaboration is extremely important
part of both high energy and nuclear
physics and it's it's worked very well I
think we indeed have our fights between
the different parts of the world but I
view it like a family the family members
are all still concerned about the
overall health of the family they may
squabble but they still have the same
goals they still work together on most
things long-range planning is extremely
important in this field since it's
dominated by these large research
facilities and long lead times expensive
facilities long-range planning is a
fortunately we have a long good history
of this going back formally to the NSF
candles in 1954 in 56 the general
Advisory Committee president Science
Advisory Committee panel meter panels of
Peoria and Ramsey National Academy of
Science committees coming out of this
this National Academy of Science panel
under Paik in 1964 initiated 64
published in 66 the elementary particle
sub channel was under Bob Walker of
Caltech we wrote a policy for national
action in high energy physics Paul
Reardon did a major part of that riding
very fricken and I've contributed some
and that was the vehicle whereby we got
the certainly one major vehicle whereby
we got Fermilab a story about that
occurred a story about that of course is
that Bob Walker had his subpanel would
finish their study of elementary
particle physics and made their
recommendations Oh certainly by November
in 1964 and frankly well you know in
science plagerism is a very bad thing
and the government is not quite the
contrary it's a very good thing why
should you try to generate something
that may well come up second-rate when
you can pull from this guy and this guy
and this guy and have the best and so
what Paul did what we did was we cribbed
entirely off of off of Bob Walker's but
Paul not here huh we cribbed entirely
off of Bob Walker as a report and put it
in there and of course along with other
things and Bob I don't think ever
completely forgave me because the
Academy was very slow publishing them
it's not too fast now but very slowly
and they didn't publish it to May of
1966 so it looked like he cribbed off of
us then
one I would like to relate to is is we
have a mini I don't they're not all here
because we have many he peps sub-panels
he pap itself it's kind of a for what is
keeping the program that's that's that's
here good and and reliable it's not the
best to look at the long-term future the
program well you may want to shut down
some of those labs instead of keeping
them going medium well and so for that
purpose one use these new facility sub
panels are so-called woods whole
sub-panels the first one of which vicki
chaired almost immediately after he was
became not no longer the chairman of he
pap itself in 1974 and at that time if i
if you recall what was on the funding
graph the construction new construction
had gone down to zilch zero nothing for
new construction okay that 1974 sub
panel chaired by vicki followed by the
1975 one chaired by francis snow coupled
with a report we wrote that talked about
long-term strategy for the for the
national program was what carried
through on what Vicky and his panel
called the three prong approach higher
energy and proton-proton collisions
higher energy and electron positron
collisions and higher energy and proton
fixed target and and that indeed led to
the the the Tevatron one and two led to
pep and whatever town wanted to keep you
both will cause colliding beam and fixed
target and also seems like it led to
something else o israel the
okay so I've alluded to it the next
thing is then how is do we advise
primary advice since 67 indeed has been
from he pal
he PAP was first meeting was in January
of 1967 one reason it wasn't earlier
than that is that we had already decided
we wanted the heap happily knew who we
wanted as chairman and that chairman and
his wisdom said he wanted to make sure
that do-e selected the site for Fermilab
before he PAP got started so if P pop
didn't get blamed for what do he did and
so when the site was selected in
December of 1966 by Atomic Energy
Commission the the meeting was followed
soon after the first three or four
meetings were all held at the Chairman's
prerogative here at MIT and that set the
tone set the the method by which he pap
operated and he pap was a was used as a
model though many variations for
subsequent standing advisory committees
and nuclear physics fusion material
science of course the program uses as
many of you as individuals knows uses
many other mechanisms and he pap and and
standing committees and advisory
committees
there's also laboratory advisory
committee so that ad hoc groups and and
there also are many telephone calls that
I'm sure many of you have received over
the years from the various program
people that do e and at NSF he okay the
indicators of a successful program the
ability to explore beyond the frontier
knowledge which cars those things
discovery of new knowledge deeper
understanding of the world physical
world the national and international
recognition awards of Nobel prizes
president science metals etc and the
programs done fairly well
by that too and I think we can say that
LNS they've done quite well by not only
certainly by the by the Nobel Prizes not
only of its faculty but also its
students but also are many other prizes
family awards president's Science Award
you name them staff members of this
laboratory have helped them so the
summary is that as a seating exciting
sighting field seeing the exciting field
it's becoming exceedingly interesting
the connections between elementary
particles and cosmology and the future
is bright for more than technology see I
have a couple more viewgraph but before
that I wanted to get back up and just
talk a while
essentially in all of the things all
aspects which might be considered
important to high energy and nuclear
physics program programs the LNS has
made truly seminal contributions you've
heard many this morning you hear many
more than the rest of the meeting and
some I'm sure will be forgotten to be
covered physics theory and experiment
education and training and the quality
and achievements of the graduate
students I wonder how many graduate
students have come out of here I suppose
you know but there must be a fantastic
number through their spread throughout
the world not a whole lot of emphasis is
being in law but there's been a lot of
accelerator work here both in R&D and
construction and design operations and
research the early cyclotron the 320 MeV
electron synchrotron the Cambridge
electron accelerator the development of
the strong focusing principle which
Livingstone with a significant
contributor to along with Kurata and
Snyder Bates let me I'd like to I don't
see it on the program let me say just a
little bit about the CEA story back the
end let's see 1949 I guess it was the
cyclotron syncro cyclotron that Harvard
was completed and not too long after
that 52 Ramsey was pushing that there
needed to be higher energy around this
region he got together with Zacharias
and Livingston in early 52 and they
agreed on a joint effort towards towards
a new accelerator in the Cambridge area
by April of 52 Stan Livingston who was
the professor here since indeed the 38
got tried they got that sought funding
from Stratton as vice president for MIT
and sought people to help with the
design study from Lee Hayward then the
director Brookhaven and wanted to go
towards the design of a 10 GeV proton
synchrotron well compromise he went to
Brookhaven that summer and during the
next very few months together with
Courant and Snyder developed a strong
focusing principle which has had a major
effect certainly on on particle and
nuclear physics but also on many other
things throughout the world certainly
one of the immediate things that has is
that CERN raised CERN which came over
shortly after this raised their sights
from a 10 Gav machined to the 28 GV
machine they built the a GS raised their
sights to 30 GeV machine and actually
got approval to build that in 1954 just
less than two years later I was
fascinated by this a paper on the
subject was published still that same
year and P afisma of 88 in 1952 they
Livingstone and Schneider paper okay
then
Stan what came back here and kept
working on proposals put in a 10 to 20
GeV proton synchrotron proposal to the
AEC in October 52 put in a 15 BV proton
synchrotron proposal in August at 53 he
ran into trouble and that the GAC the
general Advisory Committee to the AC had
said that multi BV machines they were
going of course on the pre strong
focusing principle should only be at
National Laboratories he switched to in
March of 54 he switched to a six GeV
electron synchrotron proposed it in
August of 54 to the AEC waited in 55
while the PPA Miura Los Alamos Oak Ridge
and others put in proposals for machines
and
what will you believe but to Congress on
its own I'm sure there was no influence
from here inserted ten million dollars
for two University accelerators and the
DA EC budget in in the spring of 54
there was a letter that went out from a
EC to the presidents of many
universities and July of 55 saying get
to me and three to six months a proposal
if you want to build an accelerator less
than or equal to five million dollars
this was even when I came to AC in 1962
I heard of this this was known as a box
top contest there anyway CEA and PPA won
that box top contract and CEA signed the
letter contract and April of 56 first it
was thought to be 7.9 million dollars
eventually completed in 1962 for 11 and
a half million dollars but a fascinating
story
I think the indeed the initial
initiative of Ramsey and Ramsey stayed
involved all the time but also very much
work on the part of Stan Livingston and
L&S professor and the director of the
CEA the Bates story I learned a little
bit about today even Bates of course
that started construction in 66 and I
was wondering who how it got started and
I understand it got started by Peter
demos as is saying opened his big mouth
and that they were sitting around with
sergeant
Burt OC and so forth about what could
they do next and he said well maybe we
should build a new machine and he said
they took him up on it so coming out of
that was the base machine which has done
much good research is just completing a
very major upgrading and and should do
much more okay the pattern recognition
device a pepper
Plus Rosen Sun I remember in particular
helped much help here from cute puppy on
computer development detectives many
much detective work coming here one of
the things I said that MIT received more
support in higher do physics than any
other University but many universities
receive significant levels of support
and one of my observations was when the
level of support got to be a certain top
size there would be a spallation or to
be a new group would form new leadership
and so much of the research that carried
out was much with the same statistics
but I observed that a lot of the work
that's been done in this laboratory
that's been of a larger scale and it
certainly I think has paid off for the
laboratory certainly in detectors the
world's largest was was was under the
direction of Sam King here a most
fabulous thing and under the
administrative direction of Fred Epping
and significant part from here policy
invite an advice well I guess I've said
all I should say at this time about he
PAP certainly Vicki was a major
influence on the u.s. program and
Frances law and Sid drell who is
certainly associated with this
laboratory to be pept sub-panels have
talked about in sac much much of course
policy and advice from herman fish back
from mark Herman particularly in the
nuclear physics field program funding
let me cut this a bit but I do want to
read something from the first contract
they could find for me all that do e it
was a term of the contract was April 1
1958 to and including January 31st 1959
it was for one point four million
dollars that compares with today's 20
what was 26 27 million dollars
26 yeah
and I want to read a bit on the scope of
work the contract you're showing good
faith do the best of its ability in
know-how and accordance etc conduct
eight separate programs of research and
nuclear physics which are identified as
followed scope-1 cosmic research under
the direction of Rossi scope to high
energy accelerator physics research
under Bernie Feld scope three Bob will
change your research under our Williams
scope for linear accelerator research
under Bilbo Tosi scope five onr nuclear
energy level studies under but Buettner
scope six radioactivity and cyclotron
research on a Martin Deutsch and
theoretical research under Weiskopf
Rockefeller generator program under
Sharron Berg all of it under the overall
direction of not annoyed and just so you
think that bureaucratic effects weren't
involved then under article 4 personnel
there's a phrase that says provided
however that there shall be subject to
the written approval or the Commission
reimbursement for salaries and excess of
$15,000 per year the so it's always more
than fifteen had to be approved directly
by the Commission the recent we knew or
this contract was which is accumulated
all the funding over all this this this
period added to somewhere between four
hundred and ten and four hundred and
fifty million dollars so a little bit of
money here what it's like Dirksen used
to say a billion here a billion there
I'm pretty soon you've got real money
and research a million here and a
million there and pretty soon you've got
real money
so in program funding L&S has certainly
helped the program the national program
they've also done very well themselves
but with what they putting out of course
indeed what they would take
funded for international collaboration
I'm sorry the see throughout the entire
faculty things that certainly stand out
much in my mind though is Viki truly in
internationals
of course he was the director general of
CERN 61 to 66 Sam ting the work he did
with Mark J at Daisy the work of the l3
at CERN you know I watched Sam and that
l3 and whenever he ran into money
troubles he'd first come to us
Hildebrand very reluctant to give money
to anybody it seems so he'd go off and
pull in another collaborator and you
know fantastic negotiations he must have
had having a PRC the Soviet Union the
Eastern Europe Western Europe a lot of
the lot of the US so okay I have to
actually when we're having lunch
I'd forgotten one thing that LNS
contributed and that's a government
leader one of my bosses at the
Department of fact the first boss at the
Department of Energy John Deutsch from
MIT came on to nominally head up the
Office of Energy Research but in fact
with Celestine you're spending most of
his time in the White House John from
our viewpoint ran the Department of
Energy and John and I had good and bad
interactions when he first came on he
planned to fire me but my good friend
Sid drell talked him out of it later he
told me he said Waldemar you're the
second best program director manager in
all of do e I said no I was reluctant to
ask him who was first he told me I'd
know rickover a couple of years after
that I had IDI Kentner who had headed up
in the fusion program came by
to me and said in that john deutsch and
john deutsche told him that he was a
third best program manager or a dealer
so he's consistent
the i want i like to show this tribute
grass and I'm finished another question
is what they do them oh this is the
picture of Stan Livingston a kirat and
Schneider and also John blooood at the
time of the strong focusing principle
devotes discovery and development and
things have I think gone well for the
Department of Energy for hydrogen
nuclear physics and for L&S but now you
can take this this says the air is clean
the food is nutritious and we've got
inflation licked we can go on like this
forever now whether that's a caution or
whether that's let's praise depends upon
what time you think that came in the
dinosaurs fossils the dinosaur heritage
after all they lived on earth for what
millions and millions and millions of
years much longer than we have been on
the other hand they are extinct now
you